and those characters they really it's  incredible at the way they've they've  lost I don't if you saw this but  Halloween Lady Gaga this year was Edward  Scissorhands yeah I mean she's out and  about and she bumped into a Jack Sparrow  you you do some time you do do the  dressing up his tracks bar you seem to  like that I just run around the house  like oh you you didn't you go to  Disneyland I mean that must've caused a  sensation I did I did I did something  that as soon as they you know pirates  was gonna happen I thought how great  would it be to be able to have the  opportunity to stand there is some sort  of animatronic until the people come by  and then you start screaming so you know  all these years later I got the chance  to do it so I was very excited you know  these boats you're gonna come around the  corner and and and I sort of looked at  me as they were coming around frozen it  was the proudest moment  [Applause]  [Music]